let's bring in chris sims co-host of pro
football talk and of course football
night america analyst joining us on the
program
we were just discussing the difference
between a
shuttle pass and a shovel pass
which one is correct being a former
quarterback in the nfl
um i don't yeah i don't know what a
shuttle pass is so i would say shovel
pass
is the only one i know of a sh i mean i
know how to run the
20 shuttle at the combine but i don't
know of a
shuttle pass patrick mahomes last night
had two touchdown passes
and the passes were behind the line of
scrimmage
is that a shovel pass
i i guess i would consider that a shovel
pass yes i would a speed sweep
shovel pass whatever i guess should it
count
should it count as a touchdown
i mean no not really as far as a
touchdown
pass i i don't know if i totally totally
will say i agree with that
i mean i it's a tough one actually i
haven't thought about it real deeply
it is a cheap way to get a touchdown
pass there's no doubt about that
but i'm you know patrick mahomes also
gets a lot of not cheap ways to get a
touchdown pass too to where i can live
with it you know and he can he can have
a cheapie every now and then
uh let's dissect what we saw with let's
start with the chiefs and the patriots
here because i thought
i thought belichick you know flying day
of
no cam had it had a game plan there
it just if you don't have that you know
quality quarterback
then you know you're not going to win
that game but what did you think of what
he was trying to do against patrick
mahomes in kansas city
yeah well i think you're right i mean
the game plan was really quality on both
sides of the football
and he didn't even need like a good
quarterback to maybe win that football
game or at least keep a really
competitive fourth quarter he just
needed a quarterback that wasn't
you know stupid for lack of a better
phrase i mean that just was
unbelievable some of the things we saw
brian hoyer do
i mean really i'm just shocked by that
to this point
lack of management lack of awareness of
what he's doing
all those things but back to what you
said i mean
again belichick shows why he's one of
the greatest coaches ever
he does a game plan that he just feels
like is going to help them win the
football game
it doesn't matter how pretty it looks or
whatever and
they do match up really well with kansas
city dan they really do they got the
best secondary
in football they can match that speed
and then along with
outside the box thinking from the bella
checks and then of course we know
on the offensive side of the ball i mean
there's always something creative and
they're a force running the football i
mean i know like you i couldn't help but
sit there last night and go
what is this game like if cam newton's
playing out here
and then you had uh the falcons against
the packers
and even though aaron rodgers doesn't
have his top what two
three receivers and i know it's atlanta
but there is a there is an effortless
feel watching aaron rodgers when
what changed for aaron rodgers from last
year this year
yeah i think you know you've heard him
say like you know
the the communication the offense you
know year two they're being more
creative
i do think it's the trust factor that's
really led to
the better play because one i mean
you've been watching roger you've heard
me talk about him for years
you know i think he was scarred for a
time where people weren't open that much
so
oh that's a tight window all right i
don't like that i'm not going to take a
chance
let me dance around the pocket and i'll
find an easier completion because i'm
aaron rodgers
and i could do that but it also led to
some you know moments of wait that guy
was open last year and you should have
thrown it to him
and i think this year he's just totally
bought in to where last night
i mean how many times do we see him just
look at the first receiver and he went
he's open maybe only by three inches but
i'm gonna cut it loose and throw it in
there
and to me it's just more aggressive that
way with his
frame of thinking or or my thinking
there
and their play calling is more
aggressive too i think that's the two
biggest things that jump out to me
let alone like you said atlanta stinks
on the defensive side of the ball yeah
uh speaking of winless teams the texans
uh showing bill o'brien the door is that
a coveted will that be a coveted head
coaching job
i do i do think so because of number
four at the quarterback spot i mean
desean watson
not playing his best football right now
but they got a lot of issues on that
football team
and i think you know regardless coaches
are going to look at that
and go wait i can go down there and
coach desean watson
still early in his career you know you
can still build a team around that so i
would expect
you know that's where i expect it to be
something offensively
orchestrated as far as a head coach is
that eric the enemy
is this where we hear the lincoln riley
conversation once again
from oklahoma but i would think that
they're going to be all in about an
offensive minded coach because of
deshaun watson
when do the dolphins start to give tua a
little run here
i mean i hope sooner rather than later
i mean i would like to see him get out
there where
the season's still somewhat in the
balance right
it's not like oh they're one and seven
and it's totally over
i i would like to see them out there
soon i mean you know we know what ryan
fitzpatrick is
i do find it a hair concerning that tua
and there's not more conversation about
him being out there already i think that
kind of
speaks volumes a little bit uh to the
fact that maybe he's just not running
away with it or
so impressive that they go man he's so
impressive
the team sees that everybody sees it we
got a bench fitzpatrick and play to it
you know we're doing a disservice to our
team it obviously has not got to that
but i would think
another two three losses for sure no
matter what
you're gonna start to see two of us i
know that joe burrow being the number
one pick
he didn't have any competition to be the
starting quarterback
justin herbert had a little bit with
tyrod taylor
can justin herbert be better than joe
burrow
yes he can yes no doubt about it i mean
anybody that listened to you know
listens to me and
and what i talk about draft wise
quarterback wise all those things that's
one thing i tried to say a lot joe
burrow was clearly the best quarterback
coming into this draft
but i kind of had said all along justin
herbert
has an incredibly high ceiling i mean he
has
special things about his game and yeah
he's raw and he played an
organ offense that wasn't that good and
again that's where people misevaluate
too much right now
at the quarterback position they did
they take the whole team
and they blame it on one guy and go i
don't know i mean
the stats weren't good and they didn't
win national championship
must have been justin herbert's fault no
absolutely not that's ridiculous
he's big he has a special arm i mean he
can make game-changing type
throws and you can see he knows how to
take care of the football and pro with
some accuracy too
a rookie some mistakes there but man a
lot of positives to build on
yeah i think and i agree with you
because if we're going to factor in
that joe burrows the number one
quarterback i got to factor in everybody
on that offensive
side of the ball like he had
unbelievable talent there
because i don't know if he's the first
pick overall or he's a fifth round pick
which he would have been the previous
year
and you know trying to and you do a
great job at this
but trying to look at talent at that
position and say
like jordan love i have no idea i know
the previous year when he had weapons he
was really good
then his last season he didn't have
weapons and he didn't look good at all
but was
still a first-round pick yeah it's it's
it's tough it is it's the toughest thing
about evaluating the position
it's why i've been you know hey listen i
was you know whatever
lucky whatever you want to say with guys
like josh allen and even patrick mahomes
and lamar jackson because i just went
hey just block it out don't don't have
any bias when you go in to watch this
film
evaluate the player for what he is and
then go
wait what is he being asked to do is it
realistic that he can get that done
and then also is there help around him
that's realistic to go
wait that's his fault or that's a good
job by him or whatever that is
but too often it is hard now joe burrow
where i would say it was different than
maybe some quarterbacks when you see on
like an awesome college team to like
what you're saying
he made so many plays when i went man
there was nothing there
the defense won the play they got a good
pass rush
everybody was covered and he still made
something happen
and to me that always speaks volumes
and that's something i look at because
life in the nfl unless you're on one of
the best teams in the game
is gonna be a lot of whoa the defense
won this guy's covered
i'm under under attack here and i gotta
make something happen off schedule
and that's why boro was special and i
think that's why we're gonna see justin
herbert being really special as well
but to your point too dan if justin
herbert was on lsu or alabama
they'd be just as damn good as they were
already
i mean just you know you need a team
he's chris sims co-host of pro football
talk and nbc football night in america
i just don't know what i'm seeing when i
watch josh allen because i don't know if
it's the second coming of cam newton
i i i just i'm not quite sure
yeah it's like um it's like you know
they have like the evolution of humans
right
and you know that goes from the cave man
to like
i don't know what this is i look at josh
allen and go
this is brett favre 27 years later and
the evolution of man right just
yeah plays with his hair on fire
sometimes and he does things and you're
like oh my gosh i can't believe he did
that
whoa what an amazing play i mean that's
really what he kind of reminds me of
but i think you know you're saying he's
a special talent you can see
and again that was another guy oh the
numbers and you know the grading and
oh all the you know small conference
yeah small group
small conference the crappiest team i've
seen any top top-tier quarterback play
on in the last few years
no pass protection playing in the
blizzard and all of those type of things
no help around him
but you know you see the talent and
again now they've helped him out with
getting more talent in buffalo
and brian dave ball and sean mcdermott
are really attacking through josh allen
which i think tells you a lot they trust
him
they have the weapons around him he's
refined his game
certainly and he he's he's a superstar
there's no doubt he's one of the five
best quarterbacks in football right now
as we sit here through
through four weeks all right so that's
russell wilson
yeah mahomes right aaron rodgers
right i'm still gonna go lamar
i'm going to put my bar in my top five
i'm not going to let that kansas city
game just totally throw me for a loop
for
all the other good stuff i've seen for
the last year and a half
and then yeah i'm going to throw josh
allen in there right now and i know we
want to see more and everything like
that but
what we've seen to this point is
other than russell wilson mvp level
stuff from josh allen so we'll see if he
can continue to do this but
they certainly seem confident he can
just by the way they're calling the game
and attacking it on a week-to-week basis
why are we treating the nfl mvp the way
we do the heisman
we want to hand out the heisman after
september when did we get into this rush
to say oh he's the mvp right now the nfl
after three weeks and i go it's three
weeks it's like leonard fournette would
have won the heisman
if if they ended in september when he
was in the issue
you're you're right why are we in a
hurry to like are we running out of
things to talk about where we gotta go
like how do i stir up some controversy
josh allen and russell wilson for mvp oh
hang up and listen
like well yeah i know you're oh i think
but at least in my mind what i'm doing
is i'm just trying to
paint a picture of damn this guy's
playing good football
that's all i really but you could be
playing against crappy teams you i mean
i know i know but can we wait how about
eight games can we just wait
eight games but i get it and okay i
won't say it anymore about the mvp
stuff and anything i'll i'll take your
coaching i always listen to you
but i will say too we don't have to say
mvp or anything like that
but i am sick of everybody giving like
josh allen a compliment
and prior to that they give him three
backhanded
compliments where it's like well he was
crappy and he had bad accuracy and
it's an anomaly but somehow he's good
like i'm sick of hearing that crap
he's really good he's here to stay and
in my formula with my rankings
i knew he was going to be good i'll
leave you with this if you were running
the falcons
yeah would you consider trading julio
jones
i don't know if you can trade matt ryan
but
would you would you look to rebuild the
falcon yes
yes yeah it's uh the the shelf life of
this team is over in my opinion
it's it's done they've tried to hang on
to the stars that were there that 2016
team
there's no depth of the football team at
all i mean here this is
second year in a row or third year in a
row the few injuries and their team is
shot
they have nothing else because they're
so heavy
i look at two guys where i go right now
and just go
whoa when the trade block comes around
julio jones and aj green
if i'm the bengals they got receivers
they just drafted a receiver with the
33rd pick of the draft
they're good this is the time to strike
to get assets to rebuild
your football team and yeah i would say
that if i'm arthur blank or
or the brown family in cincinnati i'm
putting them on the trade block when
that time comes around
good to talk to you chris as always
thank you continue to stir it up
all right i'm not stirring anything up
i'm just talking ball but
thank you i appreciate that and tell the
uh your you know jerk friends i said
hello my jerk
friends wow wow
thank you chris uh by the way chris says
say hello to you jerk
friends there